العوائل الأمريكية صلوات وتعازي خالص
التعازي لأهل تركيا
وسوريا
[موسيقى]
الكونجرس الأمريكي موحد ولن
نتطبيع معكم أبدًا سنحاسب
كل من يحاول التطبيع معك ولن
نتوقف عن
دعم شعب سوريا  أن تحصل
عليها
[موسيقى]
شكراً لك ، لقد
صُدمت أمريكا والعالم
بالزلزال المميت الذي ضرب طوكيو وسوريا
في 6 فبراير الذي أودى بحياة أكثر
من 50000 شخص وجرح أكثر من
مائة ألف شخص
أجنبي
لجعل هذه المأساة المدمرة أسوأ من
وحشية سوريا.  الديكتاتور المكلف
بسرقة المساعدات الإنسانية ،
والأسوأ من ذلك أنه استمر في قصف
المناطق المتضررة 10 مرات على الأقل منذ
الزلزال
[موسيقى]
أشعر بحزن عميق لأن هناك
ضعف في العقوبات من قبل
إدارة بايدن على نظام الأسد
من خلال السماح بالمعاملات المباشرة
مع  نظام الأسد ، هذا
لن يفعل شيئًا للمساعدة في إغاثة الزلزال
ولن يؤدي إلا إلى تعريض
المدنيين السوريين للخطر من خلال إثراء النظام